bonsoir à tout ce nous sommes le mardi 5
juillet vous regardez le 7 8 le journal
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition comme chaque jour nous
allons revenir sur votre actualité
locale entouré de nos invités
mais également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite on commence avec
le sommaire fin du suspense pour les
élèves de terminale les résultats du
baccalauréat sont tombés aujourd'hui
délivrance pour certains tristesse pour
d'autres nous sommes allés au lycée 17
mar à maurepas recueillir et quelques
réactions et retour sur la troisième
édition de l'innovation summer games de
l'université paris saclay organisé par
l'estac art sur son campus de saint
quentin en yvelines
l'objectif de cette initiative
familiariser les étudiants au monde de
l'entrepreneuriat et le pygargue 2
stellaire est un aigle pêcheur une
espèce menacée
l'un de ces spécimens est né il ya
quelques mois à l'espace rambouillet
dont l'une des missions principales est
justement de conserver et de protéger
ces volatiles et les vacances d'été
commencent officiellement ce mardi à 5
juillet pour les écoliers deux mois de
vacances pour se reposer avant la
rentrée des classes
on pourrait penser que c'est un peu le
plus beau jour de l'année pour les
écoliers et leurs professeurs n'est pas
forcément certains regrettent est déjà
les bancs de l'école
sephora namani et fanny bourdillon son
talent à la sortie de l'école primaire à
rimbaud à montigny le bretonneux
regardez et écoutez il ya beaucoup
d'émotion de la part des cm2 parce
qu'ils vont ne pas se retrouver à la
rentrée de 6e et surtout parce qu'ils
quittent l'école rabot mais c'est
toujours un grand une grande émotion
pour eux peut quitter l'école qu'ils ont
fréquentés pendant un certain nombre
d'années un jour ou un autre
ce triste parce que c'est une année qui
se termine voilà j'étais contente de sa
maîtresse qui vont elles passent au cp
donc c'est vraiment la fin de la
maternelle après triste mais mais je
suis quand même contente pas de changer
de classe comme ça c'est des élèves que
je quitte toujours avec regret oui il
est bon ils vont manquer un petit peu
forcément et après je vais les retrouver
puisqu'ils seront en grande section donc
je ne croiserai encore mais c'est
toujours un peu émouvant de perdre sa
classe parce qu'on les a gardées un an
donc sont pas mes enfants mais ce sont
des enfants que j'ai fréquenté un an et
le suspense a pris fin ce matin pour les
quelques six cent soixante mille
candidats au baccalauréat dans
l'académie de versailles les résultats
ont été annoncés à 10h ce matin dans les
établissements centres d'examen mélanie
poker était au lycée 17 mars à maurepas
retour sur cette matinée avec elle pas
encore deezer ces candidats sont
impatients ce lycée mort passe bien
propose les résultats de la filière
baccalauréat sciences et technologies de
la santé et du social
j'ai eu la mention assez bien et je suis
vraiment étonné parce que franchement
avoir 12 e bac alors que je pensais
avoir 10 ans fait et franchement je suis
choqué et tous les mois mais né et fier
de moi pas j'y croyais pas on est au
final je les suis vraiment très contente
parce que je croyais vraiment pas du
tout
des rires des larmes scène habituelle
ans au mois de juillet pour les 10 est
née 500 yvelinois candidats au concours
cette année
ce jour là les résultats se partage
entre amis mais aussi avec parents et
professeurs on était confiant elle a
travaillé toute l'année et elles
méritent ce résultat on est très très
fier d'elle mais je suis ravi
une seule élève à passer my téva
rattrapage beaucoup de mentions mention
assez bien mention bien donc belle
réussite pour cette case suivante pour
ces bacheliers c'est maintenant l'heure
des vacances pour ceux dont la moyenne
est entre 8 et 10 ce sera le rattrapage
jusqu'au vendredi 8 juillet et nous
avons parlé économie et innovation de
notre entretien aujourd'hui notre invité
ce soir et dominical bonsoir et vous
moquez repart donc on saura vous vous
êtes entrepreneur anciennement directeur
général de lmd est à présent fondateur
de la société
cocorico merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors vous êtes implantée à
montils l'aube retenues de 1994
aujourd'hui votre entreprise a été
racheté par la société avait là où tu es
également de montigny-le-bretonneux en
mars 2016 c'est un bouleversement
économique pour vous mais pour le
territoire
je pense que ça ça ou en tout cas des
perspectives très intéressantes sur ce
qui va se passer demain dans la nouvelle
industrie dans l'usiné du futur et on
peut prévoir en tout cas que grâce à ave
là-haut et grasse a effectivement cette
notion de réussir à apporter des
services dans le domaine de l'industrie
on va réussir aussi à apporter dans
l'industrie aujourd'hui de nouveaux
services qui vont permettre de faire de
la fabrication additive mais j'aurai
l'occasion de le développer
un peu plus tard je concert qu'elles
sont un petit peu les conséquences
justement de ce rachat déjà une
entreprise française qui rachète une
autre près ce qu'on sait c'est assez
rare alors je dirais que c'est la
croissance aujourd'hui elle se fait
plutôt dans une croissance externe
et cette croissance externe c'est
effectivement de rapprocher des pme moi
ça fait déjà depuis depuis longtemps
depuis 1994 que j'ai essayé de le faire
avec différentes entreprises pour
arriver à créer de nouveaux métiers tels
que la mécatronique et c'est vrai que
sur le site de montigny on a une
une entreprise avec des experts ou une
équipe en tout cas qui a été capable de
passer toutes ces difficultés toutes ces
dernières années et là effectivement le
rapprochement avec le groupe l'avait now
c'est une chance exceptionnelle aussi
bien pour mon équipe que pour la région
et que pour la france y avoir de
l'emploi qui va être créée sur mon
certain regard des conséquences et sur
l'agglomération alors les conséquences
déjà c'est déjà de sauver des emplois
il faut pas oublier que ont ces
dernières années on était plutôt sur un
rythme de 60 mille entreprises par an
qui disparaît c'est surtout dans nos
métiers de l'industrie
c'est à dire cas aujourd'hui nos jeunes
ont du mal à comprendre que
effectivement eu cette industrie reste
sale donc c'est pas très agréable de
travailler dans un atelier
alors que pourtant elle est
extraordinaire c'est à dire que tous les
jours on voit des produits qui sont
réalisées par des hommes qui travaillent
dans ces dans ses ateliers donc avait
naos et ça va finir sur 150 à 200
emplois
avec ce complément là ça va permettre
d'atteindre environ 250 personnes sur le
territoire
implanté sur le territoire donc c'est
une chance exceptionnelle alors depuis
1994 votre activité a évolué à ce qu'il
est facile d'entreprendre sur notre
territoire
alors je pense que 1 d'entrepreneurs
avant tout ne doit et ne doit pas faire
de garder un cap et ne trouva pas tenir
compte de ce qui a pu se passer sur le
plan politique par exemple depuis 1994
donc on doit rêver on doit avoir envie
d'avancer on doit avoir envie de créer
on a envie d'innover et puis le propre
d'un entrepreneur c'est de rassembler
des troupes autour de lui et donc
forcément de faire des embauches et de
créer cette dynamique
est-ce que c'est justement facile de
lancer des nouveaux projets convoi
l'actualité en ce moment il ya beaucoup
de l'entrepreneur qui se plaignent
justement des lois du fait qu'ils soient
bridées alors on est dans une mutation
sociétale sérum a vécu la crise là
depuis 2006 ces crises en fait compte
était pas une crise je n'ai toujours
annoncés sur les différents plateaux
j'ai pu communiquer en disant non c'est
un changement de société
de la même façon que vous êtes passé du
téléphone qui ne faisait que téléphone à
un smartphone qui fait tout je dirais
que le monde de notre société et plus
particulièrement le monde de l'industrie
est en train effectivement de changer de
la même façon et donc il faut
l'accompagner
alors difficile aujourd'hui de dire ce
qui va se passer demain pl on peut
plutôt dire ce qui s'est passé hier et
se dire que ce qui a été fait hier ç'a
permis de bâtir des fondamentaux qui
sont remis en cause aujourd'hui et ce
qui fait que vous entendez beaucoup
parlé de start up
parce que le monde a changé c'est à dire
que il ya eu une génération qui voulait
posséder aussi bien ces entreprises que
son appartement que sa voiture
et puis on est arrivé dans une
génération qui commence dès l'âge de 16
ans à faire de la colocation à partager
son frigo a partagé son vélo et ainsi de
suite donc on est dans un nouveau mode
où chacun veut avoir une certaine
autonomie et cette autonomie permet
effectivement de créer de nouveaux
emplois
de nouveaux métiers et c'est ce qui est
en train de se passer en ce moment une
progression de mutation à dans
l'industrie c'est vrai qu'on a peut-être
l'image de la chaudronnerie ou voilà
deux d'entre eux assez compliqué vous
avez plutôt travailler sur de
l'industrie mais en automobile sur des
services un petit peu dans les voitures
comment vous avez vu justement cela a
évolué au fil du temps ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'effectivement quand j'ai
créé je venais mois d'aidé du cea
commissariat à l'énergie atomique puis
après constructeurs automobiles chez psa
équipementiers et puis 1,94 j'ai décidé
de me lancer dans une aventure sol pour
essayer de créer des projets innovants
qui permettait en tout cas en france de
pouvoir créer des niches de produits 99
fut la xsara auto pc qui était la
première voiture communicants pour
citroën avait clarion ericsson et
windows et puis on a progressé sur les
terminaux informatiques embarqués pour
la police et la gendarmerie pour aller
après dans l'auto partage avec véolia fr
si city moves
auto bleue yélomobile donc on voit là
qu'il ya eu un changement entre je fais
un produit et je passe par des
intermédiaires pour levante qui à un
moment je réussis en fin de compte a
créé un vrai produit complètement
packagées qui me permet d'atteindre une
cible qui est directement la clientèle
par exemple pour l'autopartage et plus
précisément est-ce que 50 ans kevin
qu'elle avait déjà beaucoup
d'entreprises c'est bien pour les pme de
s'implanter ici est-ce qu'on a les
moyens de se développer alors je pense
qu'il est notre activité qui est en
train de se faire par le président de la
communauté des communes michel laugier
qui avait déjà été préparée avant on à
pascal ribot président de l'estac a
aussi qui est arrivé avec son école donc
c'est quand même un phénomène
extraordinaire un territoire des
universités des écoles d'ingénieurs je
pense qu'il ya tous les ingrédients en
tout cas pour pour réussir sur ce
territoire
alors vous n'êtes pas venu les mains
vides on le voit sur le plateau vous
travaillez plus tôt dans l'est dans
l'industrie automobile maintenant vous
êtes passés un peu à l'impression 3d ça
technologies de demain
alors c'est presque la technologie
d'aujourd'hui
moi j'ai commencé effectivement dans ces
séries niche en 1986 a travaillé dans
l'impression 3d avec lasteyrie auto
lithographies le frittage de poudre et
ainsi de suite essayé des technologies
fait par un ingénieur de nancy qui avait
créé cette activité qui a été délocalisé
après aux états unis et qui revient
aujourd'hui en france qui est en train
de se développer avec de nouvelles
applications parce qu'elles se sont
modernisés hélas que je suis en train de
faire simplement avec ave naos et
utiliser mes vieilles machines entre
guillemets parce qu'elles sont et
réussissent à faire des choses encore
exceptionnel aujourd'hui où on fabrique
des copeaux c'est à partir d'un blog si
vous voulez vous enlevez de la matière
et vous fabriquer le produit est là l
inverse aujourd'hui c'est que l'on va on
va créer par exemple un produit comme
celui ci où à partir de celui ci ça va
être une charnière et on va utiliser le
juste nécessaire pour faire en sorte de
créer un produit qui va être fait en
impression 3d est là en métal
et qui va pouvoir être utilisé dans
l'industrie pour ces salles et dans les
mains ça a été fait une imprimante vous
imaginez votre imprimante de bureau sauf
qu'elle est dans le métal là et vous
fabrique ce produit là alors vous êtes
aussi
dans le cas on est plutôt dans le
ferroviaire l'automobile et l'aviation
et puis vous imaginez aujourd'hui dans
le domaine médical par exemple les
prothèses de dents vont être faites
directement avec des machines
d'impression 3d c'est à dire plus besoin
de faire des contexte compliqué je
répète encore on n'est pas parti d'un
blog pour réaliser la pièce on est
partis du juste nécessaire pour trouver
la solution
la grêle est exactement la même chose on
est sur un système pour les dentistes
on est dans le tout ce qui est animation
3d donc ça c'est un petit personnage par
exemple pour des dessins animés qui a
été fait c'est en dépression 3d et vous
voyez que vous avez aussi les couleurs
et la définition de pratiquement de la
chemise au détail près avec une usure en
plus
et puis vous arrivez ici si vous faites
une usine vous pouvez la craie avant les
couleurs vont sortir en même temps
couche par couche et vous allez avoir
votre usine en 3d avant de la réaliser
assez accessible au grand public c'est
déjà aujourd'hui d'accord voilà
stationnement et ça va se passer encore
à une échelle encore plus importante
grâce à les deux en tout cas fondateur
de vannes et à vannes et aux industries
deux groupes avaient now les lits et
sébastien vire creuse qui sont dans
cette croissance et qui vont permettre
effectivement sur ce territoire de le
rendre en 3d avec ce que vous nous avez
dit les écoles les soutiennent alors
justement ou par les écoles très bonne
transition on va parler dans un instant
de l'estac à l'école d'ingénieurs qui à
montigny le bretonneux l'organiser un
summer cup pour familiariser les
étudiants au monde de l'entrepreneuriat
pour vous c'est une bonne chose
justement de rapprocher d'inciter les
étudiants à se lancer alors mon être
dans toutes les sociétés depuis 24 ans
j'ai toujours eu des stagiaires aussi
bien en alternance que ce soit au niveau
des bas que ce soit au niveau de
l'université ou d'ingénieurs et il était
en alternance et ça me permettait de
sélectionner limite les meilleurs qui
restaient dans l'entreprise donc c'est
une formidable opportunité que d'avoir
effectivement cette école ingénieur
proximité et justement que les élèves
peut-être face en parallèle et les
antilles et de vie de leurs études et
deviennent en même temps entrepreneurs
voilà ce qu'ils vont vivre c'est qu'ils
sont en train de préparer effectivement
ce monde en 3d
c'est un monde qui est sans tabou
j'emploie souvent un mot qui paraît
peut-être un peu surprenant mais je
pense qu'effectivement beaucoup de gens
aujourd'hui de notre époque on de la
nostalgie et c'est jamais bon de se
promener avec 2 il s'agit je crois qu'à
un certain moment il faut se projeter en
avant
effectivement le monde demain fait peur
tout simplement parce que l'on nommé
koné mais quand on a cette connaissance
et qu'on connaît les produits
on avance beaucoup mieux demain dans
l'avenir et par rapport à ce qui se
passe aussi sur un plan politique je
pense que la montée de l'agressivité est
souvent à la hauteur de l'incompétence
et c'est parce que effectivement on
n'arrive pas à maîtriser les choses
qu'on est souvent effectivement dans
cette crise un peu compliqué donc
formons nous l'estaca on est une bonne
preuve et nos entreprises sont en train
d'avancer dans le bon sens merci
beaucoup à dominique et moi car les
bonus sur notre plateau et d'avenir si
répondre à nos questions et nous aurons
parlions il ya quelques instants donc la
semaine dernière l'estac a accueilli la
troisième édition de l'innovation ce mot
requiems de l'université paris saclay
sur son campus qui est situé à saint
quentin en yvelines
une cinquantaine d'étudiants de toutes
disciplines confondues s'étaient
rassemblés le but de l'innovation summer
games étant de sensibiliser les
étudiants à l'entrepreneuriat et à
l'innovation
michael almy d'euros émanant la batte
pour ce reportage
47 étudiants se sont rassemblés pendant
cinq jours pour la troisième édition de
l'innovation summer campe de
l'université paris saclay lui projet
était centrée sur la problématique des
nouvelles mobilités les idées ne
manquaient pas dans le hall de l'estaca
quelques heures avant le verdict du jury
c'est une application pour faciliter le
transport en commun dans la ville et
donner un côté plus sociale au transport
en commun c'est super intense mais ça
fonctionne
c'est génial c'est une méthode vraiment
qui vient d'arriver en france voit que
c'est un des premiers stages qui est
fait en france aujourd'hui en google
sync sprint est ce qu'on peut produire
en une semaine c'est incroyable des
cabines et pourra mettre des mois pour
le faire et c'est vraiment
révolutionnaire ça décuple les capacités
de chacun dans notre équipe il y as de
l'informatique du design de la pharmacie
de l'agroalimentaire de l'économie du
social donc on est une équipe de six
personnes
vraiment on n'aurait pas pu se
rencontrer dans d'autres événements et
c'est ça qui permet de créer des
solutions qui sont intéressantes parce
qu'on a une approche et une vision des
choses qui diffèrent dans l'amphithéâtre
de l'école d'ingénieurs les noms des
lauréats sont dévoilés prix du public et
coup de coeur du jury sont décernés au
même projet st bernard qui prévoit
d'aider les personnes atteintes
d'alzheimer à se déplacer à rentrer chez
elle grand gagnant de cette édition opi
une application pour faciliter le
transport en commun le rendant plus
agréable du coup maintenant falloir se
pencher sur la question après qu'est ce
qu'on fait on est une petite 2,6 donc on
vient de gagner un prix le but c'est
quand même dû continuer projet de montée
donc voilà on va se pencher sur ce qu'on
fait avec ce projet est ce qu'on va
pouvoir
voilà ce qu'on va pouvoir en faire une
récompense permettant de continuer cette
dynamique entrepreneuriale le concept du
groupe opi pourra bénéficier d'une
dotation de 3000 euros pour lancer sa
propre start up
il est temps à présent de passer à notre
chronique nous parlons à présent de
politique mais aussi de culture bonsoir
florane c'est une nouvelle tension à
saint quentin en yvelines après les
échanges tendus autour de l'aménagement
du territoire entre majorité et
opposition c'est à présent un conflit
sur la programmation culturelle qui
vient d'éclore alors un conflit autour
de la programmation de la salle du pré
semailles en cours plus précisément
trois spectacles n'ont pas été validés
pour la saison 2016 2017 et pour
l'opposition comprenait les élus de
gauche il s'agit d'une censure d'une
décision inadmissible et surtout d'une
intervention d'une commune en
l'occurrence de celle d'el encore dans
l'élaboration et de la programmation
d'un équipement intercommunal sous
responsabilité donc de l'agglomération
de saint quentin aisne nous sommes allés
à poser à la question à son président
justement au président de
l'agglomération voici sa réponse
aucun spectacle n'a été retiré de la
programmation puisque
il s'agit il s'agissait dans un premier
temps d'une proposition de programmation
dont je pense que il est tout à fait
normal que les élus puissent décider et
valider une programmation voilà donc un
travail a été fait par la directrice du
prisme qui nous a présenté un programme
et nouba nous avons validé mais il ya
des choses qui ne satisfaisait pas donc
nous avons demandé qu'ils aient
changement changement qui porte sur
trois spectacles sur 40 proposées dont
je pense que on a largement validé la
programmation qui nous a été faite c'est
une tempête dans un verre d'eau
il est tout à fait normal que dès qu'un
élu chargé de la culture dans une
commune où est installé le prisme puisse
participer aussi à la programmation de
cet équipement qui attire de nombreuses
et courtois pour michel laugier vous
l'avez entendu il n'y a pas matière à
polémique néanmoins collectif a vu le
jour mais lent particulier associatif
représentants du monde culturel avec un
soutien des politiques également un
collectif qui a mis en ligne une
pétition pour exprimer son
mécontentement face à cette situation ce
qui a fait réagir ses de l'intervention
du politique au niveau de la
programmation et de choix des spectacles
c'était quand même quelque chose
d'inédit et en 40 ans d'existence du
prisme jamais jamais le politique
n'était intervenu dans le choix des
spectacles
ils ont toujours laissé faire les
équipes culturelles qui ont analysé les
besoins qui après on fait la
programmation est défini donc les
spectacles et le représentant du
collectif de s'inquiéter de la place
accordée à la culture à 50 ans écouté le
à nouveau et écouter ensuite la réponse
de michel logis on n'aime jamais voir le
politique intervenir je vais dire au
niveau des programmations je veux dire à
partir du moment où commence à décider
ce qui est bien ou mal que ce soit en
terme de programmation de spectacles il
faut quand même rappeler que les trois
spectacles ont été déprogrammés et un
spectacle de jazz un spectacle de danse
et un spectacle théâtre humoristique
y'a vraiment pas la politique
un danger politique majeure mais on peut
toujours s'inquiéter de l'intervention
du politique dans les choix je vous dis
aujourd'hui c'est le prisme et les
spectacles du prisme demain pourquoi pas
le cinéma et le choix dans les films ou
alors dans les médiathèques le collectif
résistance à la culture en résistance à
quentin en yvelines est à une structure
informelle pour l'instant mais il est
déjà prévu plusieurs réunions et
rencontres notamment vue de la rentrée
scolaire dans la rentrée des spectacles
en septembre je pense que la culture a
toute sa place à saint quentin le budget
de la culture est odieux est toujours
aussi important sur saint quentin et
nous souhaitons justement continue à
développer l'ensemble de nos actions et
suffit de voir le budget qui a été voté
dernièrement par les élus de saint
quentin
il suffit de voir les programmations il
suffit de voir tous les services offerts
à la population pour se rendre compte
que la politique de la culture est
toujours aussi dynamique et toujours
aussi performante à saint quentin en
yvelines
après l'aménagement du territoire après
la culture aussi d'autres sujets de
tension devrait sans doute voir le jour
à la rentrée une raison est très simple
à cela les élections les élections
législatives bien sûr merci wilfried et
à propos justement de l'agglomération
cette information qui concerne les
nouvelles technologies le réseau italie
thouars vient de classer
saint-quentin-en-yvelines troisième
agglomération la plus active de france
sur twitter pour renforcer son lien avec
les acteurs de son territoire saint
quentin en yvelines a d'ailleurs lancé
une contribution via les réseaux sociaux
twitter facebook ou encore instagram
auprès des internautes pour l'aider à
établir le diagnostic préparatoire à ce
nouveau projet de territoire vous pouvez
interagir avec l'agglo l'agglomération
pardon sur twitter avec son adresse
@ sky est ce qu y parlons environnement
à présent la protection des espèces et
notamment des volatiles est une des
missions de l'espace rambouillet cette
année il a vu naître son 20e pygargues
de stellaire un aigle pêcheur rares et
menacées l'espèce est classée vulnérable
dont la liste rouge de l'union
internationale pour la conservation de
la nature
une fierté pour le parc nous avons
rencontré ce gros bébé ce matin les
images son cinéma
bat il est beau il est un peu gauche se
pygargues de stellaire est née le 26
mars à l'espace rambouillet et il a déjà
a bien grandi à l'âge adulte il peut
peser jusqu'à 9 kg et mesurer deux
mètres cinquante d'envergure en milieu
naturel sont énormes beck lui permet de
pêcher des poissons et même des jeunes
phoques mais on ne trouve plus beaucoup
dans la nature
en 15 ans la population de cette espèce
a presque diminué de moitié
c'est un mail aux pêcheurs qui mangent
des poissons en réussite et beaucoup de
pme compagnies pétrolières qui
s'installe et qui déverse beaucoup de
produits dans les fleuves qui sont
gérées par un poisson et comme l'aigle
pêcheur mange du poisson
voilà c'est lui qui en pâtit c'est le
20e spécimens mais aussi est le seul en
france cette année
une fierté pour le parc la conservation
des espèces et l'une de ses missions
principales
depuis 1995 l'espace rambouillet
participe activement au programme
international de sauvegarde du pygargue
de stellaire aujourd'hui on a mis en
place avec nos naissances de pygargues
dostaler on la refait 5 5 couples qui
sont répartis dans d'autres parcs donc
enfance à l'étranger l'objectif c'est de
multiplier les couples d'avoir beaucoup
de jeunes et peut-être que dans 20 30
ans pour à réintroduire des jeunes dans
le milieu naturel
on peut observer l'aigle pendant la
démonstration de vol aux côtés de ses
congénères une espèce peut-être rare
mais pas pour le public de l'espace
rambouillet et on reste dans les carnets
de naissance avec l espace rambouillet
d'autres bébés ont vu le jour au parc
est celle d'un aigle impérial qui met
fin mais vous voyez c'est petit oiseau
blanc sur les images une espèce qui se
reproduit très mal en captivité peu de
parcs ont la chance de les voir se
reproduire il y avait également
the royal habituellement elle vit au
nord des états unis là vous voyez qu
elle était très curieuse et intrigué par
notre caméra les jeunes saint quentinois
ont du talent c'est en tout cas ce que
pense la ville de voisins-le-bretonneux
en partenariat avec le centre alfred de
vigny le service jeunesse de la commune
organisait ce samedi son premier
concours de jeunes talents de la magie
de la danse du chant une trentaine de
jeunes s'est produit sur scène
même hypothèse a assisté au spectacle
regarder elle est douce et timide
elle va nous arriver nous interpréter
maman de la chanteuse doivent donc à
tonnerre d'applaudissements comme meriam
ils sont plus d'une trentaine à avoir
tenté leur chance
ils ont entre 11 et 25 ans et participe
au concours des jeunes talents de
voisins-le-bretonneux je fais de la
musique depuis longtemps depuis toujours
mais j'avais envie de faire un petit
concert comme ça profitant de l'été puis
en plus il y avait un peu de talent donc
connaître pourquoi pas si loin de
s'amuser tout en étant un départ timide
c'est une expérience si ça nous permet
de faire des séances de la semaine
comment ça se déroule à deux sorties
après six mois de répétitions ces
candidats sont évalués par un jury
d'experts
jules de radio sensations andy de déclic
théâtre ou encore un membre du conseil
municipal des jeunes suivent une grille
d'évaluation de la grande partie
techniques artistiques et après il ya le
volet ces lignes le bonus finning le
bonus l'insee si on a bien ressenti ou
pas si on a aimé c'est le petit plus si
les effets chaud au coeur ou si nous
importe roady après il y aura technique
et artistique
c'est l'emplacement de la scène comment
la personne arrive à s'en sortir
le concours est né de la collaboration
de plusieurs partenaires notamment le
service jeunesse de la commune et le
centre alfred de vigny
c'est de mettre en avant les jeunes donc
de 11 à 25 ans de l'émeute 'rester un
espace scénique de les faire monter sur
scène avec des talents que ce soit dans
le domaine du chant dans domaine musical
il ya aussi de la magie
y'avait aussi éventuellement des arts du
cirque pour cette première édition c'est
aymeric 12 ans imitateur de michael
jackson qui l'emportent pas de palme
pour les autres mais ils ont déjà
conquis le public et c'est à présent la
fin de cette édition je remercie de nous
avoir suivis restez avec nous tout de
suite vous avez rendez vous avec nicolas
kirillovitch pour le site huit sociétés
objet du débat le bric site et ses
conséquences
je retrouve demain pour un nouveau
numéro du journal je vous souhaite donc
une excellente soirée et à demain